hi schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid bei
ZDF heute live ja heute hat der
US-Präsident Joe Biden verkündet bei der
US-Wahl 2024 noch mal anzutreten und das
hat er mit so einem ca 3 Minuten lang
Video getan das wäre vielleicht heute
schon bei Instagram oder bei Twitter
gesehen habt er sagt darin jede
Generation habe einen Moment in dem sie
für die Demokratie und die Freiheit
einstehen müsse und er schreibt dazu bei
Twitter ich glaube dies ist unsere das
Motto dieses Kampagnen Videos ist let's
finish this job also auf Deutsch lasst
uns diesen Job zu Ende bringen ja und
darauf gibt's jetzt gemischte Reaktionen
am heutigen Tag während die einen sagen
ja der hat doch bisher ein ganz guten
Job gemacht sagen andere hallo dieser
Mann ist viel zu alt um noch mal zu
kandidieren das sagen auch Leute in der
Demokratischen Partei er ist mit 80
Jahren bereits jetzt der älteste
Präsidentin der Geschichte der
Vereinigten Staaten und im Wahljahr wäre
er dann 81 Jahre alt
jetzt heißt also 2024 wahrscheinlich
wieder beiden versus Trump wie diese
Kandidatur einzuschätzen ist darüber
spreche ich heute mit ziemlich vielen
Leuten zum einen mit Alexandra hablin
sie ist zdf-korrespondentin in
Washington mit Benjamin wolfmeier er ist
Mitglied bei den Republicans oversees
mit Candice charison sie ist Mitglied
bei den demokrattes Brot und mit Michael
Werte es Politikwissenschaftler am
Center for American progress und wie
immer spreche ich nicht nur mit denen
über diese Themen sondern auch mit euch
da draußen habt ihr Fragen an unsere
Gäste oder wollt ihr vielleicht einfach
mal eure Meinung zum Thema loswerden
loswerden dann schreibt sie uns entweder
hier im Youtube Chat oder per Mail an
ZDF heute - live.at zdf.de bevor wir
aber alle miteinander sprechen spreche
ich jetzt erstmal mit meiner Kollegin
Alexandra havelin in Washington die uns
hier live zugeschaltet ist hallo
Alexandra
hallo Viktoria
Alexandra Joe beiden hat sich ja ein
ziemlich besonderen Tag heute für diese
Ankündigung rausgesucht oder
ja das Timing ist tatsächlich
bemerkenswert genau heute nämlich vor
vier Jahren zur selben Uhrzeit also 6
Uhr früh morgens Ortszeit hat er schon
einmal ein Video gepostet indem er sich
ums Weiße Haus beworben hat und beiden
ist ja bekanntlich abergläubisch ersetzt
also diesmal auf dasselbe Datum dieselbe
Uhrzeit und dieselbe Methode kein großes
Tamtam keine große Rede sondern eben das
Video du hast es gesagt etwa 3 Minuten
lang und mir ist dabei aufgefallen vor
allem drei Punkte sind da interessant ne
also zum einen verrät er das
wahlkampf-motto wie du es schon sagtest
letzten Job ja ähm er stellt sich da als
der der Schützer der Demokratie der
Freiheiten
und ähm er positioniert sich da ganz
klar gegen seinen Herausforderer Donald
Trump und seine Anhänger die sogenannten
Republikaner und auffällig ist auch
drittens dass die Vizepräsidentin Kamera
harry ist sehr oft im Video zu sehen ist
deshalb können wir annehmen dass sie
tatsächlich auch zum zweiten Mal sein
sogenannter running made ist ähm sie
soll für eine jüngere Generation
sprechen stehen und Communitys
ansprechen wie zum Beispiel die schwarze
und die asiatische
eine ganze Menge die dieses Video
transportiert was sind denn so die
ersten Reaktionen heute aus den USA auf
diese Kandidatur und auf das Video
also es wurde erwartet dass Joe Biden
noch mal Antritt der hat es ja schon
lange angekündigt aber seit heute ist es
eben offiziell interessant ist die so
Vertreter der Demokratischen Partei
stehen fast geschlossen hinter ihm
Senatoren abgeordnetes
Repräsentantenhaus die stehen
geschlossen hinter ihm wenn man aber auf
Umfragen schaut unter demokratischen
Wähler dann sieht die Sache etwas anders
aus ungefähr die die Hälfte also 51% der
demokratischen Wähler die bei den
Vorwahlen dann tatsächlich über den
präsidentschaftsdem Kandidaten der
Demokraten abstimmen die sind gespalten
also 50% sagen sie wünschen sich nicht
beiden und wenn man auf die große
Masse der Amerikanerinnen und Amerikaner
blickt dann sagen in Umfragen 70% der
Amerikaner bei beiden ähm soll nicht
mehr antreten und der wichtigste Grund
warum sie das sagen ist tatsächlich sein
Alter ist aktuell 80 Jahre alt am Ende
einer zweiten Amtszeit wäre er 86 Jahre
also die Frage der Fitness fürs Alter
wird er beantworten müssen die wird über
dem Wahlkampf stehen aber Joe Biden hat
in der Vergangenheit schon gesagt
vergleicht nicht vergleicht mich nicht
mit dem Allmächtigen vergleicht mich mit
der Alternative und wer ist derzeit die
Alternative es scheint so dass es der
Herausforderer Donald Trump ist auf der
Seite der Republikaner natürlich es ist
noch lange hin bis zu den Vorwahlen und
es ist noch nichts fest aber wenn es
Donald Trump ist dann hat Joe beiden
eben sehr gute Chancen wenn ich die
besten Karten er hat bewiesen dass er
schon mal gegen Donald Trump gewonnen
hat aber und das muss man auch dazu
sagen sollte es anders kommen als
derzeit die Umfragen zeigen sollte die
Republikaner sich für einen jüngeren
oder anderen
Präsidentschaftskandidaten entscheiden
dann könnte es tatsächlich eng werden
für die beiden
ja das ist alles noch ziemliche
Zukunftsmusik über die wir gerade
sprechen lass uns vielleicht noch mal so
einen Blick zurückwerfen das sind denn
bisher so die politischen Erfolge die
Joe Biden vorweisen kann
ja sehr oft wird einfach nur über das
Alter gesprochen deshalb ist es glaube
ich wichtig auch zu gucken was er auf
dem Papier vorweisen kann und da sieht
seine Bilanz sehr gut aus also im Inland
und dem Ausland also zuletzt bei den
Zwischenwahlen hat sich gezeigt er hat
da ein historisches Ergebnis eingefahren
also die zwischen waren im November die
gelten als Zwischenbilanz für die
Amtszeit eines Präsidenten da wird er
meistens abgestraft da hat Joe Biden und
die demokratener historisches Ergebnis
eingefahren sie haben die Mehrheit im
Senat halten können und sie haben ihm
Repräsentantenhaus die Mehrheit zwar
verloren aber nicht so große Verluste
eingebüßt das zum einen und dann gibt es
noch eine Reihe von auch über
parteilichen Gesetze die Joe Biden
verabschieden konnte allen voran das
große
infrastrukturpaket das klingt jetzt
vielleicht langweilig oder sperrig aber
beeinflusst viele Amerikanerinnen und
Amerikaner über eine Billion Dollar wird
aufgewendet um die Infrastruktur des
Landes zu erneuern also
brückenstraßen Schienenverkehr helfen
Flughäfen und auch ein das Netz an
Ladestationen vor E-Autos soll ausgebaut
werden und das ganze soll auch tausende
Arbeitsplätze schaffen
er hat auch den sogenannten Inflation
reduction Act verabschiedet das ist ein
milliardenschweres Klimaschutz und
sozialpaket er hat im Dezember erst ein
Gesetz verabschiedet dass
gleichgeschlechtliche ähnlich schützen
soll und er hat ein Wahlversprechen
gehalten und schon erfüllt ungefähr vor
einem Jahr er hat mit catanji Brown
Jackson die erste schwarze Richterin in
den obersten Gerichtshof nominiert und
wenn man international guckt also für
die transatlantischen Beziehungen ist
Joe Biden ein sehr stabiler beständiger
Partner auf dem man sich verlassen kann
was derzeit auch sehr wichtig ist wenn
wir über die Unterstützung für die
Ukraine sprechen da ist die Vereinigten
Staaten sind unter Joe Biden gerade die
wichtigsten Geber was Waffen angeht was
Finanzmittel angeht und und
Informationen und da kann man sich auf
Joe Biden verlassen was bei seinem
Vorgänger Donald Trump nicht immer der
Fall war
ja das ist ja zumindest bis hierhin mal
eine ganz vorzeitbare Bilanz danke
Alexandra für den neuesten Stand aus
Washington
und ein weiteren Blick auf diese heute
verkündete Kandidatur der Demokraten hat
Benjamin Daniel für uns geworfen
kein großer Auftritt keine Inszenierung
lediglich dieses Video postet das Weiße
Haus um Punkt 6 Uhr Ortszeit Joe Biden
wirft für die Präsidentschaftswahl 2024
seinen Hut erneut in den Ring er teilt
hart aus gegen jene die Demokratie und
Freiheiten oder das Recht auf Abtreibung
einschränken wollen
vier Jahren angetreten bin habe ich
gesagt wir kämpfen um die Seele Amerikas
und das tun wir noch immer wir müssen
uns der Frage stellen ob wir in den
kommenden Jahren mehr Freiheit und
Rechte oder weniger haben wollen ich
weiß was ich möchte und ich denke sie
auch
[Musik]
mit 80 Jahren ist der bereits jetzt der
älteste US-Präsident aller Zeiten viele
sehen das als Problem auch unter den
Demokraten dennoch muss der Amtsinhaber
wohl nicht mit ernsthafter Konkurrenz
aus den eigenen Reihen rechnen auch
seine Stellvertreterin Kamera Harris die
viele zu Beginn ihrer Amtszeit als
mögliche oval office-kandidatin gesehen
hatten soll auf ihrem jetzigen Posten
bleiben und so kann sich Joe Biden auf
seine republikanische Konkurrenz
fokussieren neben Donald Trump der seine
Bewerbung ja bereits eingereicht hat
rechnen Beobachter damit dass auch
Floridas Gouverneur Ron des Säntis
früher oder später ins Rennen einsteigen
wird und so ist spätestens ab heute klar
der Wahlkampf in Amerika für 2024 hat
begonnen
[Musik]
ja und auf diesen Wahlkampf und die
Kandidaturen wollen wir jetzt sprechen
und das tue ich gemeinsam mit zwei
Studio Gästen die mir zugeschalteten zum
einen mit Candace Carsten von den
demokrats die wir hier schon sehen aber
auch mit
hier habe ich einen falschen Namen mit
Herrn wolfmaier von der überseegruppe
der Republikaner ich freue mich dass Sie
bei uns sind
schönen guten Abend danke schön
ich fange mal bei der Demokraten an wir
haben heute diese Kandidatur von Joe
Biden vernommen Frau Harrison es gibt da
ja auch Kritik dran warum entscheidet
man sich bei den Demokraten jetzt wieder
für Joe Biden den auch in der Partei
viele zu alt finden
sei er einfach in den ersten drei Jahren
einen erstaunlich gut super Job gemacht
hat also wirklich alles was er in den
letzten drei Jahren seine ersten
Amtszeit
durchgemacht hat und auf ermöglicht hat
fürs Land und für die Bevölkerung ist
bemerkenswert also ihre Kollegen hat
gerade drüber gesprochen also wirklich
investieren in unsere Infrastruktur in
unsere Menschen und ähm wirklich in
Rekord Höhe und man kann über sein Alter
sprechen und sagen ja mit 81 ist ja zu
alt also man muss aber auch beachten
dass 81 Millionen Menschen für ihn 2020
abgestimmt haben und damit zufrieden
sind
Herr wolfmeier sie sind ja Teil von den
Republicans over season also von der
republikanischen Vertretung in
Deutschland wie blickt man den in ihrem
politischen Lager heute auf die
Verkündigung dieser Kandidatur
gut das war jetzt keine Überraschung
mehr das Joe Biden heute seine
Kandidatur verkündet hat obwohl ich
lange Zeit geglaubt habe dass er nicht
noch mal antrete und nach den
Zwischenwahlen vielleicht zurücktreten
würde um Kamera Harris dran zu lassen
aber ich glaube in Demokraten ist klar
das können ziemliche Katastrophe als
Präsidentin wäre insofern nicht gesehen
und nicht dieser Folge von denen meine
Kollegin gesprochen hat die sehe ich
überhaupt nicht ganz im Gegenteil vor
allem die drei hauptversprechen oder
drei Hauptthemen hat Joe Biden überhaupt
nicht eingelöst allen voran die Erhöhung
des Mindestlohns der aber dann den
republikanischen Bundesstaaten dafür
erfolgt
Frau Harrison wie reagieren sie da drauf
her beiden hat seine drei großen
Wahlversprechen nicht eingelöst sehen
Sie das auch so nee überhaupt nicht
leider sind wir nicht einig Herr
wolfmeier Joe Biden
tatsächlich gemacht das sieht man das
hat man bereits in den ersten Tagen
gesehen wir sind dann wieder ins Paris
klimakkord eingestiegen was für Menschen
wie ich also mit 30 sehr bedeutsam ist
für unsere Zukunft hat sich dann stark
auch für für Arbeiter gemacht und in
sehr Infrastruktur also ist es wirklich
was er im ersten Wahlkampf gemacht
hatten jetzt auch für dich auf 2024
wieder machen wird ist eine Wahlkampf
und eine Präsidentschaft für alle
ermöglichen
schon den Kopf genau da muss ich dann
doch noch mal also zumindestlohn habe
ich ja bereits erwähnt wie gesagt der
sollte auch 15 Dollar erhöht werden da
hat er sich überhaupt nicht darum bemüht
eine sehr wichtiges Thema aber auch zum
zum Beispiel die Erhöhung des
Kindergeldes noch unter Donald Trump
beschlossen wegen der kurvit Pandemie
hat der auslaufen lassen aber auch die
Krankenversicherung für die besonders
Armen die extra für COBIT erschaffen
wurde hat er jetzt auch auslaufen lassen
das sind die sogenannten Brot und Butter
Themen die die Leute interessieren die
Leute interessiert nicht irgendwelche
Toiletten für Transsexuelle oder anderes
natürlich das sind alles Nischen äh
Themen die eine ganz kleine Klientel
erreichen aber damit erreichen sie nicht
die Sorgen und Nöte und es gibt 5
Millionen weniger Beschäftigte als vor
der Kurve Pandemie wo ja ein
Beschäftigungsrekord nach dem anderen
fand also es gibt überhaupt nichts zu
feiern aber er hat das Rennen eröffnet
und wir freuen uns auf einen spannenden
aber auch harten Wahlkampf
bei einem überparteilichen Infrastruktur
gesetzt Paket mit einem hohen
Fördervolumen und dem Inflation Act mit
einem hohen Fördervolumen jetzt von
Nischen Themen zu sprechen ist aber auch
übertrieben oder
an ich habe ich habe von den Toiletten
für Transsexuelle beispielsweise geredet
dass dadurch aus Themen auch bei sind
bei diesen beiden Gesetzen darum ist es
ja auch überparteilich passiert ist ja
gar keine Frage aber es sind halt nicht
die drei Hauptpunkte und am Ende ist
halt das Geld wie viel Geld haben die
einfachen Arbeiter zur Verfügung
Arbeitsplätze das ist erstmal das
allerwichtigste und dann kommen andere
Themen dran
und amerikanische Produkte zu schützen
da hat Präsident beiden ein bisschen auf
kleinen Präsident Trump gemacht das hat
er sich gut abgeschaut aber damit zu
sagen er hat eine gute Bilanz
vorzuweisen insgesamt und auch
außenpolitisch ist es ja eine
Katastrophe
ja sehe ich einfach nicht und ich glaube
die Mehrheit der Amerikaner auch nicht
Frau Harrison wie sehen Sie das
noch ergänzen kann also ich würde so
Transsexuelle also verschiedene Gesetze
die gerade so Vorwürfe die gerade
besprochen werden also das ist nicht es
geht nicht nur um einen einziges Thema
das ist insgesamt wofür wir als Land
stehen und wir stehen für Offenheit wir
stehen für Freiheiten wir stehen für
unsere Rechte und das ist wichtig und
apropos so für Menschen einsetzen wenn
wir jetzt über so Kinderbetreuung oder
ja
Sozialleistungen jetzt sprechen wollen
es sind die Republikaner die Social
Security unsere Rentenversicherung jetzt
abschaffen wollen es gibt tatsächlich
welche die das ganz ganz weg möchten und
ähm also das ist krippenpaar also für
Menschen für Arbeiter ist man ganz klar
bei den Demokraten auch bei Freiheiten
und Rechten vor allem als Frauen aus
junger Menschen Frauenrechte
unsere Klima also ja es könnte nicht
klar sein also diese Lüge dass die
Republikaner die Krankenversicherung
abschaffen und die Rentenversicherung
privatisieren wollen wir hatten eine
Krankenversicherung auf privater Basis
geschaffen das war Präsident Obama wenn
ich dich daran erinnern darf also das
ist wirklich nicht wahr und vor allem
nicht bezogen auf Donald Trump der nie
diese Position hatte ganz im Gegenteil
ähm also das muss ich dann doch noch mal
auf schärfste drücken da sind wir
ja auch okay dass da möchten Sie
noch was ich wollte einfach sagen also
ich meine wir haben uns sehr oft 2020
gesehen und ich finde das einfach
ja erfrischend irgendwie wieder über
Themen zu sprechen das darf man nicht
vergessen das heißt Trump an der Macht
war ging es immer nur darum wieder was
hat schon heute gesagt oder dies getan
oder irgendwas und es ist einfach schön
wieder bei den Sachen zu reden was man
sagen
über Sachen reden können aber sie
wollten ja oder ihre Partei eine Partei
wollte ja lieber über Donald Trump und
sein Auftreten reden als über die
Inhalte
uns und nicht an Donald Trump wir
möchten hier aber noch mal über Donald
Trump sprechen das ist ja der
voraussichtliche Kandidat der
Republikaner und gegen den laufen ja
gerade ziemlich viele Verfahren und
Untersuchungen Herr wolfmeier glauben
sie Trump hat da trotzdem eine Chance
ja gerade also wenn Sie das aktuelle
Verfahren was in New York läuft von dem
demokratischen Bezirksrichter
eingeleitet ist eine reine Phase jeder
weiß dass es reiner Wahlkampf
eine reine Wahlkampfmaschine die da
läuft das wird ihm helfen jetzt schon
bereits hat er sehr sehr viele Spenden
eingesammelt seitdem das ganze gestartet
ist von Leuten die vorher noch nie zuvor
für einen Politiker Geld gespendet haben
das heißt dass
ärgert sogar Leute die eigentlich mit
Politik nicht viel am Hut haben weil
hier wird versucht von einem
demokratischen und das noch mal
demokratischen Bezirksanwalt den
wahrscheinlichen
Präsidentschaftskandidaten der
republikanischen Partei und
Herausforderungen aktuellen Präsidenten
nämlich ich glaube beiden
vor Gericht zu bringen um ihn zu schaden
solche Methoden die den Gegner zu
diffamieren und fertig zu machen kennen
wir sonst nur aus südamerikanischen
afrikanischen Ländern aber nicht aus den
USA also das Moment da muss ich einmal
nachhaken gegen den demok deutschen
Präsidenten Joe Biden laufen doch
derzeit auch Verfahren bezüglich
geheimer Akten das ist ja jetzt keine
ganz einseitige Sache dass hier nur in
eine Richtung ermittelt wird ich habe ja
jetzt von dem New Yorker Verfahren was
ja im Moment das Hauptverfahren ist das
andere da wird ja noch überlegt ob sie
überhaupt ein Verfahren machen da läuft
ja noch gar kein Verfahren wenn Sie auf
diese Akten Sachen ansprechen das stimmt
da ist ja bei etlichen Leuten diese
Akten gefunden worden aber auch das auch
wenn es bei beiden dann auch wäre also
das ist auch ein propans mit diesen
Akten man hat natürlich gehofft dass man
die nur bei Trump findet dass man sie
dann bei beiden gefunden hat da hat man
sich dann halt verkalkuliert aber um das
aktuelle Verfahren
wurden dann geht das ja auch ja also das
ist auch nichts wirklich gravierendes da
wird irgendwas hochgeschaukelt von
Bilanzfälschung und Wahlkampfspenden
betrug aber da steht auch so dünn Weinen
das wissen alle aber darum geht es auch
nicht es gibt ich würde sagen da warten
wir noch mal bis diese unter suchungen
auch zu Ende sind was ich mich jetzt
noch Frage müssen wir denn jetzt
nächstes Jahr wenn es da zum Showdown
kommt und ähm wir nehmen jetzt mal
vielleicht an der Ausgang ist das Joe
Biden das gewinnt und Trump verliert
müssen wir dann wieder damit rechnen
dass Republikaner oder Demonstranten da
das Capitol stürmen
ja also von unserer Seite aus natürlich
nicht sie haben natürlich nie Einfluss
wer unter Demonstranten mit dabei ist
das war auch letztes Mal nicht so das
Präsent Trump dazu aufgerufen und das
Capitol zu stürzen
ne das hat ja der Untersuchungsausschuss
veröffentlicht im dezember 2022 belegt
ja diesen Untersuchungsausschuss den
würde ich dann so sehr infragezeichen
stellen wenn man sich einfach die von
damals aktuellen Tweets anguckt von
Donald Trump auch das was er bei der
Rede am 6 Januar gesagt hat so hat er
betont immer wieder dass die friedlich
verlaufen soll der Fehler lag natürlich
daran dass die Sicherheitsbeamten
ziemlich bewusst die Demonstranten die
sich dann Richtung Capitol gemacht haben
einfach durchmarschiert haben lassen ich
glaube das von bestimmten politischen
Kräften die ist sogar gewollt war um ihr
Schaden zu haben um die ihn dann
verwerten zu können aber
der 6 Januar kein Wahlkampf das können
die Demokraten gerne machen Sie bitte
Wahlkampf mit dem 6 Januar verschießen
sich darauf damit werden sie null Punkte
gewinnen
schon den Kopf
ja das war ein trauriger Tag für unsere
Nation muss man sagen und das ist schon
bewiesen dass Donald Trump daran
beteiligt wurde und nicht nur also
beteiligt soll der Menschen dazu
aufgerufen hat das ist also das lässt
sich nicht streiten Herr wolfmaier um da
so ein bisschen Klarheit in die Sache zu
bekommen würde ich sagen wir gucken uns
einfach noch mal einen Beitrag genau zu
diesem Thema an den meine Kollegen Jonas
ganzelmeier und Jonas Kap für uns
vorbereitet haben
Washington DC 6 Januar 2021 radikale
Trump Anhänger stürmen gewaltsam das
Kapitol und randalieren in der
Herzkammer der amerikanischen Demokratie
Trump zieht sich als Wahl Gewinner
spricht von Wahlbetrug
wir wollen nicht dass unser Wahlsieg von
den radikalen Linken Demokraten
gestohlen wird
ein Untersuchungsausschuss wird
eingesetzt der soll Erkenntnis über
Trumps Rolle bei der Capitol er Stimmung
liefern im dezember 2022 veröffentlichte
Ausschuss seinen Abschlussbericht die
Vorwürfe gegen Trump wiegen schwer an
Stiftung zum Aufstand und Betrug gegen
die USA sind darunter
wir haben Beweise das Präsident Trump
bewusst den friedlichen Machtübergang
gestört hat den unsere Verfassung
vorschreibt
der Sturm aufs Kapitol und Trumps Lüge
des gestohlenen Wahlsiegs beide
Ereignisse hängen zusammen der USA
Georgia nach der Wahl dort leitete die
justizermittlung ein der Vorwurf war
Beeinflussung ein Telefonat zwischen
Trump und Georgia's Innenminister
ich will einfach nur
11.780 Stimmen finden es kann nicht sein
dass ich Georgia verloren habe das kann
nicht sein wir haben mit
hunderttausenden Stimmen gewonnen
juristische Anhaltspunkte dafür dass Joe
Biden nicht der rechtmäßige US-Präsident
ist gibt es bis heute nicht
ja so viel zu dem was wir da gerade
besprochen haben wir haben es ja jetzt
eben gehört Anstiftung zum Aufstand und
auch handfeste Beweise gegen Trump Herr
wolfmeier wie verantwortungsvoll ist
denn sowas in einer Demokratie es gibt
keine Beweise jedenfalls hat keiner sie
bisher vorgelegt und wird wahrscheinlich
auch nicht vorlegen weil sie nicht gibt
ja gerade gehört dass es die gibt ja
aber dann muss man die auch vorlegen
also nur zu sagen man hat Beweise ist ja
kein Beweis an sich
wie gesagt nehmen Sie die Rede die ihr
gehalten hat am 6 januar oder hat er
extra dazu aufgerufen das ist friedlich
bleiben soll er hat auch in
verschiedenen Tweets vor seiner Rede
aber auch danach dazu aufgerufen das
ganze friedlich zu beenden und so weiter
also ne ich glaube das ist hier von
einem bestimmten Kräften entweder
gesteuert wurde oder dass ich ein paar
wenige von den interessantes waren ja
hunderttausende Demonstranten da
verglichen mit der Menge die dann das
Capitol gestürmt hat was ich
ausdrücklich auch nicht gut finde
ja ist das ein kleiner Anteil die sich
dann selbstständig da berufen gefühlt
haben irgendwas zu machen den
Hintergrund kann ich verstehen ich
glaube auch dass die letzte Wahl nicht
fair gelaufen ist und ich glaube auch
dass da gerade in Pennsylvania betrogen
wurde aber das ist ein anderes Thema das
rechtfertigt aber nicht das was am 6
Januar passiert ist und das klar und
deutlich zu sagen das ist nicht die Art
und Weise wie man so einen Konflikt den
es da gibt äh löst und von daher aber
wenn sie dann Trump hat dies weder
angeordnet noch unterstützt noch
bevorfeuert das sind reine Märchen der
Demokraten und wie gesagt nur zu sagen
wir können das beweisen aber dann keine
Beweise vorzulegen zeigt er dass man
keine Beweise hat und hier sage ich noch
mal es ist belegt das ist bis heute
keinen Anzeichen für einen Wahlbetrug
gehabt Frau kiristan was erwarten Sie
sich denn von dem Wahlkampf nächstes
Jahr
ja sich heute auch dazu sagen also wir
hatten auch die mitturns im letzten
November und das war wieder dann ein
Glas ein ganz krass Zeichen gegen die
Magic republicians so Trump Trump
Anhänger also viele seine Kandidaten
haben verloren weil sie einfach zu
extremen ihre Positionen für die meisten
Menschen im Land waren also das darf man
nicht vergessen also jetzt denken wir
ganz nach vorne auf 2024 ähm der
Wahlkampf steht an Menschen die auch im
Ausland wohnen sind bei uns willkommen
auf jeden Fall also alle die einen
US-amerikanischen Pass haben dürfen aus
dem Ausland wählen und wir hoffen dass
Sie das auch tun
das hoffe ich auch für die Republikaner
ja wir merken vielleicht schon an dieser
Diskussion das wird sicher eine
spannendes nächstes Jahr und ein
spannender Wahlkampf mal vielen Dank
dass ihr bei uns waren sehr gerne danke
schön
ja überall das wollen wir jetzt
natürlich noch mal sprechen und das noch
mal genauer analysieren und zwar
gemeinsam mit Michael Wertz er ist
Politikwissenschaftler am Center vor
American progress und uns jetzt
zugeschaltet herzlich willkommen
schönen guten Abend nach Mainz
Herbert sie haben ja die Diskussion
gerade verfolgt was erwarten Sie sich
denn persönlich vom Wahlkampf nächstes
Jahr
das ist relativ schwer abzuschätzen man
muss sich immer vergegenwärtigen dass es
noch 17 Monate sind bis zur Wahl das
heißt wir haben eine ungeheuer lange
Vorlaufzeit und auch der Kandidat oder
die Kandidatin auf der republikanischen
Seite ist noch nicht bestimmt auch wenn
es im Moment so aussieht als ob Donald
Trump die besten Karten in der Hand hat
knapp die Hälfte der republikanischen
Wählerinnen und Wähler unterstützen ihn
sein wichtigsten gegen Kandidaten Ron
der Santos aus Florida unterstützen nur
20 bis knapp 30 % je nachdem welcher
Umfrage man Glauben schenken möchte aber
es ist äh nicht
seriös jetzt zu sagen wie der Wahlkampf
im Sommer kommenden Jahres aussehen wird
was interessant ist wenn man sich die
Ankündigung der Kandidatur für Joe Biden
ansieht also das Video was ihre Kollegen
vorhin beschrieb so scheint die
Demokratische Partei und das Weiße Haus
davon auszugehen dass Donald Trump der
Gegenkandidat wird weil diese
Positionierung von Joe Biden ist ganz
klar darauf ausgerichtet die
wahrgenommenen Schwächen eines gegen
Kandidaten Donald Trump aufzuzeigen und
daraus politisches Kapital zu schlagen
ja lassen Sie uns noch mal auf das Alter
dieses Kandidaten gucken das wird ja
gerade viel diskutiert und
eine Umfrage des Nachrichtensenders nBC
hat ja auch ergeben dass selbst unter
den Demokraten 51% sagen Joe Biden solle
nicht mehr als Präsident antreten und
von denen ist knapp für knapp die Hälfte
das Alter der Grund wie muss man sich
das denn vorstellen gibt es bei den
Demokraten in den USA keine jungen
engagierten Leute
doch die gibt es es gibt eine ganze
Reihe von potenziellen Kandidaten aber
diese Entscheidung war keine
Entscheidung des Parteivorstandes oder
einer Parteiversammlung sondern es war
die Entscheidung eines einzigen Mannes
nämlich des Präsidenten Joe Biden der
Joe Biden nominiert hat und sich
entschieden hat noch einmal das Amt zu
verteidigen insofern ist diese
Diskussion jetzt erledigt die
demokratischen potenziellen
Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten werden
Ihnen unterstützen 81 Jahre ist ein
hohes Alter da haben sie völlig recht
das ist allen bewusst die hier in
Washington oder auch an anderen Orten
politischer aktiv sind auf der anderen
Seite ist das amerikanische politische
System so ausgelegt dass es nicht
einfach einer Entscheidung eines
Parteivorstandes oder einer
parteivversammlung bedarf um einen
Kandidaten oder eine Kandidatin aus
aufzustellen sondern hätte Joe Biden
signalisiert in diesen Tagen dass er
nicht kandidieren würde wäre zum einen
seine Präsidentschaft in den kommenden
anderthalb Jahren politisch lahmgelegt
gewesen und zum anderen hätte es einen
breiten flächendeck
in den Wettbewerb gegeben unter 7 8 9
oder vielleicht sogar zehn
demokratischen Kandidatinnen und
Kandidaten die dann in den Vorwahlen im
nächsten Jahr sich hätten miteinander
auseinandersetzen müssen das heißt beide
Wege sind risikobehaftet und der
Präsident hat entschieden dass er noch
einmal in der Lage ist zu kandidieren
seine Frau unterstützt ihn Jill Biden
war lange Zeit sehr skeptisch und wollte
nicht dass er noch einmal kandidiert das
hat sich offensichtlich geändert und so
beides auch der Auffassung dass er
Donald Trump nicht nur einmal sondern
zweimal schlagen kann insofern erübrigt
sich diese Diskussion zumindest
innerhalb der Demokratischen Partei ein
Stück weit man muss auch sagen dass im
Vergleich zum vergangenen Sommer als
noch dreiviertel der demokratischen
Wählerinnen und Wähler sich ein anderen
Kandidaten wünschten diese 50%
Kritik jetzt an seinem Alter in gewisser
Weise eine Verbesserung darstellt weil
Joe beiden innerhalb der Partei bewiesen
hat mit den Zwischenwahlen im
vergangenen November die relativ
erfolgreich verlaufen sind das wurde
erwähnt in ihrer Sendung dass er
durchaus jemand ist mit dem man Wahlen
nach wie vor gewinnen kann
ich habe gerade mal so einen Blick in
die Kommentare geworfen und da gibt es
eine Frage die wahrscheinlich gerade
Menschen umtreibt ich lese ihn einfach
mal vor hier schreibt jemand was macht
eigentlich seine Vizepräsidentin ich
hatte große Hoffnung auf sie gesetzt da
sagen wir als aktuell viele dieser in
der bisherigen Amtszeit ja recht im
Hintergrund erschienen
ja das ist eine sehr gute Frage wird
auch intensiv diskutiert hier schon seit
vielen Monaten in Washington Kamera
Harris hat in gewisser Weise die
Erwartungen nicht erfüllt sie hatte eine
schwierige Ausgangsposition in die sie
sich in gewisser Weise selbst hinein
manövriert hat weil sie ja in den
Vorwahlen des Jahres 2020 als sie sich
noch um das Präsidentschaftsamt oder die
Kandidatur beworben hat Joe Biden in
einer der Vorwahl Diskussionen sehr
scharf angegangen ist und ihm
rassistische Politik in seinen jüngeren
Jahren vorgeworfen hat man muss sich
immer für gegenwärtigen Joe beiden kommt
aus einer anderen Generation er ist
Anfang der 70er Jahre zum ersten Mal
Abgeordnetenhaus gewesen da war er 28
Jahre alt das war eine Zeit als Elvis
Presley noch Konzerte gegeben hat also
schon eine Weile her und sie hat ihm
vorgeworfen dass er in den 70er Jahren
Gesetzgebung unterstützt hat die
afroamerikanerinnen und Amerikaner zum
Nachteil gerechte das hat sehr viele
Verletzungen und Verärgerung in beiden
Kämpfen vor gerufen unter anderem auch
in seiner Familie in sonst insofern war
es für camera Harris nicht einfach als
vizepräsidentschaftskandidatinnen und
dann gewählte Vizepräsidentin erst
überhaupt einmal ein Verhältnis zum
Präsidenten zu entwickeln das vom
Vertrauen geprägt war dadurch hat sie
sozusagen einen Start Nachteil gehabt
wenn man so will und zum zweiten hat das
Weiße Haus ihr auch sehr schwierige
Themen wenn man das freundlich
ausdrücken will über antwortet nämlich
sie musste nach Zentralamerika um zu
versuchen die Migrationsströme
einzudämmen sie hat politisch wirklich
herausfordernde Aufgaben gehabt wo man
sagen kann fairerweise da gab es
überhaupt nichts zu gewinnen für sie
insofern ist ihr Auftreten hier in der
Öffentlichkeit sie hat doch einige
Interviews verstolpert nicht besonders
stark aber wenn man sich wieder das
Video ansieht mit dem der Präsident
heute seine Kandidatur verkündet und
konformiert hat spielen dort zwei Frauen
eine große Rolle nämlich Gilden seine
Gattin und Kamera Harris die
Vizepräsidentin und das deutet auch auf
ein wichtiges Thema dieser Kampagne hin
das neben den Fragen der amerikanischen
Demokratie und der Verteidigung der
amerikanischen Demokratie beiden sagte
in diesem Video es ist jetzt keine Zeit
selbstgefällig zu sein sondern wir
müssen kämpfen um die demokratischen
Traditionen des Landes dass ein zweites
wichtiges Thema ist nicht nur
abtreibungsrechte im Besonderen sondern
auch Rechte und Gleichberechtigung von
Frauen im Allgemeinen und dafür ist kann
Maler Harrys natürlich eine ganz
wichtige Botschaft darin
wir haben hier noch mal eine eher
technische Frage zum politischen Betrieb
in den USA hier fragt sich jemand wie
wird man denn eigentlich Kandidat bei
den Parteien ist das der der die meisten
Spenden zusammen kratzt
die geld spielt eine wichtige Rolle aber
nicht die allein entscheidende Rolle der
Donald Trump hatte weniger Geld als
Hillary Clinton in der 2016er Wahl bei
den Vorwahlen der Republikaner hat Jeff
bush der Bruder von George W Bush die
größte Kriegskasse gehabt und hat
trotzdem gegen Donald Trump die
Nominierung verloren also Geld spielt
eine wichtige Rolle es ist entsetzlich
aber wahr dass eine Präsidentschaft
Wahlkampf hier zwischen 1,5 und 2
Milliarden Dollar kostet aber es ist
nicht da allein entscheidende Faktor das
Nominierungsverfahren selbst ist
ungeheuer kompliziert beide Parteien
wenn es neue Kandidaten sind das fällt
jetzt im Falle der Demokraten weg weil
der Präsident sagt ich werde noch einmal
antreten aber im Normalfall müssen
Kandidaten ab Februar kommenden Jahres
also ab Februar das Wahljahres in allen
Bundesstaaten sukzessive gegeneinander
Wahlkampf führen und dann werden auf
bundesstaatsebene Abstimmung abgehalten
durch die dann auf Landesebene
definierte Delegierten vergeben werden
diese Verfahren sind in beiden Parteien
unterschiedlich bei den Demokraten
werden die Delegierten die sogenannten
Wahlmänner und Wahlfrauen entsprechen
den prozentualen stimmanteilen an die
Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten vergeben
bei den Republikaner ist es so wie bei
den bundeswahlen auch dass derjenige
oder diejenige die den Bundesstaat
gewinnen alle Delegierten aus diesem
Bundesstaat bekommen das ist auch einer
der Punkte der Donald Trump zum Vorteil
gereicht weil es keinen Kandidaten im
Moment gibt in dem Bewerberfeld der über
eine 20 bis 25%
unverrückbare und komplett auf ihn
orientierte Unterstützungsgruppe in
allen Bundesstaaten verfügt und wer dann
die Mehrheit in diesem
bundesstaatswahlen die sich bis in den
Juni des kommenden Jahres hinziehen
werden erhält der wird dann auf dem
großen Partei Kongressen der
republikanischen demokratischen Parteien
nominiert als Präsidentschaftskandidat
und dann geht es im Herbst also nach
leberday ab der zweiten Septemberwoche
in den bundeswahlkampf
also ein Ungeheuer langwieriges
Verfahren und durch die Primaries also
die Vorwahlen innerhalb der Parteien
natürlich auch ein gefundenes Fressen
für den politischen Gegner weil dort
versuchen sich Leute aus der gleichen
Partei gegeneinander zu profilieren zum
Teil auch mit sehr harten
Auseinandersetzungen also uns bestehen
17 stehen 17 recht unterhaltsame Monate
bevor die ein hohes Maß an politischer
Nervosität auch hier in Washington und
in den USA insgesamt verursachen werden
das klingt auf jeden Fall ganz schön
kompliziert lassen Sie uns jetzt
abschließend noch mal ein bisschen aufs
inhaltliche kommen und auf die
politische Bilanz von Joe Biden aktuell
es gibt ja Stimmen die sagen er hat sehr
viel erreicht in seiner bisherigen
Amtszeit wir haben verschiedene Pakete
gehört das überparteiliche
infrastrukturpaket wir haben vom
Inflation reduction Act gehört jetzt hat
Herr wolfmeier von den republicians
overse gesagt eigentlich hat er gar
nichts erreicht der hat seine größten 3
war Versprechen nicht eingehalten wie
würden sie das schaffen Joe bidens denn
bis jetzt bewerten
also die das müssen ihre Zuschauerinnen
und Zuschauer selber entscheiden aber
die Fakten sind das Joe Biden in den
ersten beiden Jahren seiner Amtszeit
drei große gesetzespakete durchgebracht
hat die wurden ja auch schon erwähnt in
ihrer Sendung und nur einmal um das zu
vergegenwärtigen diese drei
Infrastruktur und
subventionsgesetze und klimagesätze
haben ein Gesamtvolumen das ungefähr dem
achtfachen des deutschen
Bundeshaushaltes entspricht das heißt
hier ist ungeheuer viel Geld auf die
Schiene gesetzt worden um
Infrastrukturmaßnahmen und sozialen
Ausgleiche Reduktion von Krankenkosten
und erneuerbare Energien in den
Vordergrund zu stellen das war auch
bitter notwendig weil wir hier in den
USA 20 Jahre lang im Irak und
Afghanistan Krieg geführt haben und
dieser Krieg uns jeden Tag über 200 $
Millionen Dollar gekostet hat das heißt
das sind sozusagen nachholende
Investitionen die lückenstopfen mussten
die in die Infrastruktur in die sozialen
und andere Sicherungssysteme des Landes
gerissen worden sind durch den die
Invasion im Irak und in Afghanistan und
das Interessante ist dass die Mehrzahl
dieser Gelder dieser ungeheuren Volumina
die da freigesetzt worden sind
konservativen Bundesstaaten zugute kommt
aber das übersetzt sich nicht wie sie ja
zu Beginn ihrer Sendung auch sagten in
politische Unterstützung für Joe Biden
also ist ein ganz interessantes Phänomen
das hier Leute durchaus auch soziale
Infrastruktur und andere Investitionen
erhalten Arbeitsplätze geschaffen werden
aber sich das nicht zurück übersetzt in
politische Unterstützung weil diese
Zuwendung natürlich dann den Anspruch
genommen werden aber dann aufgrund der
ideologischen und politischen
Verhärtungen die wir hier im Moment in
den USA erleben die Leute sagen trotzdem
werde ich diesen Präsidenten nicht
unterstützen also insofern eine
interessante Gemengelage relativ
kompliziert und ich glaube wer sich
ansieht was Joe Biden und die
Administration in den letzten
zweieinhalb Jahren getan hat und das
dann sozusagen gegen liest gegen das was
in den vier Trump passiert ist der oder
die kann sich dann eine eigene Meinung
relativ schnell und sachkundig bilden
ja und sie leiten schon schön über im
Prinzip zu meiner letzten Frage oder
auch der Frage eines Users kam hier
gerade im Chat hier wird gefragt im
heutigen politisch gespaltenen Amerika
wie äußern sich die Amerikaner selbst
tendenziell zur politischen Landschaft
sie haben es gerade angesprochen das ist
ja ein zutiefst ideologischer eine
zutiefst ideologische Debatte die da
gerade geführt wird man hört immer
wieder vom Kulturkampf wohin führt das
denn Amerika gerade
ja das ist eine ganz harte Situation man
kann das vielleicht am besten daran
verdeutlichen dass vor den großen
Familienfest hängen es giving also dem
Erntedankfest dass wir hier im November
feiern immer in den großen Zeitungen
Beratungs Texte veröffentlicht werden
wie man denn das Familienabend Essen mit
politisch anders gesonnenen
Familienmitgliedern am besten managt und
überlebt das heißt es kommt zu ungehören
Verhärtungen viele Leute reden nicht mit
mehr miteinander das für Familien ist
das eine ganz schwierige Situation aber
man muss sich auch für gegenwärtigen
dass nicht nur der 6 Januar also der
Sturm aufs Kapitel den ich den nicht
mehr aus sicherer Entfernung persönlich
angesehen habe und muss sagen das war
eine der Einstein politischen Erfahrung
für mich persönlich in den vergangenen
10 oder 20 Jahren sondern auch die
Tatsache dass dann eine dreistellige
Zahl von Abgeordneten die Zertifizierung
des Wahlergebnisses verweigert hat und
damit im Prinzip gesagt hat die
230-jährige Tradition demok
sympathischer und gewaltloser
Machtübergabe in den Vereinigten Staaten
durch Wahlen stellen wir in Frage das
greift tief und das berührt auch die
Grundfeste dieses Landes darum auch für
Joe Biden wieder das Video die
auftaktsequenz der 6 januar und die
Frage von abtreibungsrechten für Frauen
das sind die zentralen Themen mit denen
er Wahlkampf führen wird weil das Themen
sind die die Zukunft des Landes die
Frage des Umgangs miteinander und auch
die Frage in welcher Zukunft wir in den
Vereinigten Staaten leben nicht nur im
Landesinneren sondern auch im Verhältnis
zum Rest der Welt entscheiden
beeinflussen wird und das sind Themen
die dann hoffentlich auch im Wahlkampf
für ausgefochten werden so dass die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger sich eine
Entscheidung Grundlage verschaffen
können basierend auf der sie dann ihre
Wahlstimme abgeben in der ersten
Novemberwoche 2024
ja und bis zu dieser November
waren über diesen Wahlkampf über die
Kandidaturen über das politische
Geschehen in den USA sprechen Herr Wert
vielen Dank dass Sie sich meinen Fragen
und den Fragen der Community gewidmet
haben danke schön
ganz herzlichen Dank an meins
ja ich hoffe ihr habt jetzt ein bisschen
ein klareres Bild und sieht das
vielleicht heute als Auftakt für etwas
über was wir wie ich gerade schon gesagt
habe bis nächsten November
wahrscheinlich noch häufiger sprechen
werden ich danke euch für eure
regelbescheinigung und für eure
Kommentare und Fragen und sage bis zum
nächsten Mal